[Música]
noticias de la salud con Natalia plazas
Natalia Buen día para usted Buenos días
Ángela un tema polémico e importante es
el de hoy hablamos sobre fumar y el
consumo de cigarrillos y electrónicos y
convencionales Reino Unido lanzó un plan
con el que busca reducir al mínimo el
consumo de tabaco para el 2030 Pero la
pregunta es si Esta técnica que va a
usar va a servir no bueno va a ser la
pregunta del millón y vamos a ver por
qué Reino Unido es uno de los países que
en toda Europa más ha luchado por
reducir justamente el consumo del tabaco
y lo ha logrado o sea tiene unas cifras
que realmente han reducido drásticamente
concretamente en 2011 el consumo de
cigarrillos en mayores de 18 años
rondaba el 20% y ahora
en 2021 bajó hasta un 13,3% sin embargo
el gobierno británico sigue teniendo una
meta muy ambiciosa que es lograr que
para 2030 este consumo se reduzca al 5%
y en medio este mega plan ambicioso del
gobierno
lanzó otro plan que se llama el plan
Swap to stop o intercambiar para parar
concretamente de lo que se trata este
este nuevo plan es distribuir a gran
escala concretamente un millón de kits
de inicio de vapeo entre los fumadores
de Reino Unido entre uno de cada cinco
fumadores en Reino Unido este plan va a
ir acompañado también con apoyo
conductual para las personas que
necesiten dejar de fumar y para las
mujeres embarazadas que concretamente
las mujeres embarazadas alcanzan a ser
entre las mujeres fumadoras alcanza a
ver un 9% que siguen fumando estando
embarazadas va a haber apoyos incluso
económicos que pueden llegar hasta las
300 libras también otra parte de este
plan es pedir que las tabacaleras
incorporen consejos para dejar de fumar
en las cajetillas de cigarrillos con
todo esto el gobierno pretende disminuir
las por consumo de tabaco y también
aliviar el peso sobre el sistema
sanitario en Reino Unido Ángela recuerdo
muy bien Natalia que con su colega más
Romero hemos hablado ya en el pasado de
los vapeadores y no han salido muy bien
parados en general esto ya es una
realidad y se aplicará Durante los
próximos años sin embargo que dicen a
los expertos de salud respecto a la
opción de cambiar un cigarrillo
convencional por un vapeador bueno Pues
estudia realizados por el gobierno de
Reino Unido consideraron Y estos
estudios también fueron realizados por
pares por otros expertos consideraron
que promover el vapeo podría ser bueno
para digamos en disminuir el consumo de
tabaco en algunas poblaciones sin
embargo advierten de riesgos de estos
aparatos que también son altamente
adictivos recordemos Ángela para ahondar
sobre estos riesgos hablamos con el
doctor Luciano Rusia director de la
asociación Suiza para prevenir el
consumo de tabaco y esto fue lo que nos
dijo
químico que los vapeadores
contienen es muy variable que allí todos
enfabricado en China y nunca sabemos
exactamente
Qué sustancias químicas contienen en los
análisis de laboratorio ahora que tienen
nivel preocupantes de metal o de metales
pesados y no están que no están en los
cigarrillos clásicos y además solo
llevan unos pocos años en el mercado y
no sabemos nada de sus efectos a largo
plazo sobre la salud pero el experto
también indica que para dejar de fumar y
sobre todo para disminuir el consumo de
nicotina a gran escala en las
poblaciones son varias las medidas que
hay que tomar entre estas está reducir
drásticamente el precio del tabaco
disminuir en la publicidad y Bueno hay
otras medidas y estas fueron las que él
señaló
y cada vez más restricciones sobre dónde
está prohibido de fumar y vapear
se necesita también un millón apoyo
psicológico y sería mejor de aumentar el
límite de venta de estos productos todos
los productos como a 23 25 años porque
el cerebro desde joya hasta esta edad y
hasta esta edad la nicotina tiene un
impacto muy mucho más fuerte bueno como
decíamos es un plan que no deja de
generar algunas polémicas Porque además
podría entre otras beneficiar a la
industria Tabacalera y a los fabricantes
de los cigarrillos electrónicos que al
final incentiva Pues el consumo No claro
Ángela y es un plan que como dices está
creando muchas dudas de que por
disminuir el consumo de tabaco
concretamente realmente se esté haciendo
digamos un mal pacto no el pacto que
acaba incentivando también otros
productos que también Vienen muy
cargados de nicotina como señalas
justamente Además él las tabacaleras
han de alguna forma dado respaldo o se
han mostrado
a favor de este plan que está
desarrollando el gobierno británico
veamos cuál fue la redacción de la
Philip Morris que es justamente la mayor
Tabacalera del mundo
apoyamos el compromiso del Reino Unido
de ayudar a los fumadores adultos a
dejar los cigarrillos pero ahora el
gobierno debería adoptar la gama
completa de productos alternativos
basados en la ciencia disponibles Pues
bueno Yo ahí no voy a opinar la
población adulta sin embargo Natalia no
es la única de que preocupa respecto al
consumo de cigarrillos electrónicos en
el país porque la situación entre los
adolescentes llama la atención de las
autoridades esto acarrearía muchos
costos para el gobierno en el sistema de
salud No por supuesto acarrea muchos
costos tanto para niños para
adolescentes bueno para adolescentes
principalmente y para
personas ya por encima de los 18 años
algunos expertos en pediatría sin
embargo han advertido que es en el país
se están enfrentando a una epidemia del
vapeo
dicho esto aprovechamos para repasar
también unas cifras que deja un informe
publicado el año pasado pero realizado
sobre 2021 y que nos muestran un poco
este impacto que tienen los vapeadores
en la población adolescente si miramos
en 2014 solamente el 7% de los
adolescentes consumían vapeadores y esta
cifra ya ha aumentado hasta un 17%
estamos hablando recordemos de niños
adolescentes de entre 14 y 15 años por
lo que es bastante grave esta situación
tenemos que también entender un poco que
estos riesgos entre los adolescentes
puede ser que a largo plazo en sus vidas
estas personas pueden tener más
facilidad de desarrollar otro tipo de
adicciones y que también se pueden
se puede se pueden
desarrollar
daños en sus cerebros debido a que es
una población mucho más vulnerable a la
nicotina Ángela Bueno pues el consumo de
tabaco sigue siendo un tema diríamos en
lo alto de las noticias de la salud y
todavía muy difícil de manejar gracias a
usted Natalia gracias Ángela